I'm hoping it's released sooner than
later but I know Disney's super excited
about it they bought it from Fox
where I used to. I used to work and
Is Deadpool also Fox?
Deadpool yeah was Fox and then now
it is in the hands of Marvel over there
at Disney. Yeah and what and can
those worlds be combined or we
don't know. I know, I see so much
infinite possibility in either version
you know if Deadpool were to be in the Marvel
comic universe I think or the Marvel
Cinematic Universe rather I think it
would be explosive and amazing and what
a sandbox to play in
if Deadpool continued to get to just do
his own thing and be his own thing also
just like infinite possibility and you
know I mean we have I know. I do I write
it with two other guys Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick who are geniuses
and amazing in you know in so many
ways and and we just have so much fun we
actually write it all right in here in
this room where I'm sitting and we
just had the best time doing it together
so we hope that we're. There's a lot more
more story to tell so we hope
we get to do that sooner than later. There's a couple
jokes that you told me about I won't say
now because I don't want to ruin the
third one but it didn't make it to the
second one but it was really really
funny thing that was like oh they'll never let you do that.
yeah you could fill a gymnasium with
some of the jokes that got cut out of
Deadpool 1 & 2 that would get us all
arrested or turned into some sort of Disney Liquid.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Deadpool 3 video big
surprise Ryan Reynolds is talking about
the movie recently on Fallon so we'll
break it down there's also a bunch of
Easter eggs that he posted to his
channel a while ago too he's been
posting Easter eggs in the background if
you haven't noticed so it's always good
to keep an eye on what he's posting if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your Deadpool 3 predictions on the
video I'll start by talking about all
the Deadpool stuff that he reveals in
the clip here of the deleted scenes the
jokes and the MCU stuff that he talks
about then I'll talk about those other
Deadpool Easter eggs that he dropped
separately from this clip so starting
with number 5 if you don't know what's
going on Ryan Reynolds was on Jimmy
Fallon recently talking about Deadpool 3
and some of the other projects that he's
got going on he was actually shooting a
movie with the rock when they had to
shut down because of the virus he was
just in the Fast and Furious to spin off
if he wondered why he showed up in that
movie apparently he's been friends with
the rock for a long time he said they
spent a lot of time on their movie says
trying to get each other to laugh during
scenes number 4 the longer conversation
that he has with Jimmy Fallon about
Deadpool
in the MCU makes it sound like one Jimmy
Fallon has no idea what's going on with
the Deadpool Marvel stuff in the MCU but
the way Ryan Reynolds addresses that he
makes it sound like Marvel has not
totally decided how they're going to handle
Deadpool 3 other than doing it as a
rated R movie like will there be other
pre-existing characters from other MCU
movies crossing over into Deadpool 3 or
are they just going to do it off as its own
thing and pretend like it's not in the
MCU the only thing that all the people
involved with Deadpool at Marvel and all
Ryan Reynolds and his people the
creatives that actually work on the
movies have said in common is that
they'll allow them to continue making
r-rated Deadpool films what's really in
question though is how they treat him
when he's crossing over with other MCU
characters and whether or not they
decide to put Deadpool 3 in the MCU the
Disney CEO Bob Iger said many times that
he's not going to force them to go pg-13
just for the sake of being under the
Disney brand even though they did that
funny experiment with once upon a
Deadpool there was even a promo for that
movie where he shouts out Disney off he
g13 it's a family movie also money also
Disney that was Ryan Reynolds just
having a little bit
before the buyout was done but Kevin
Feige said that they don't have any
plans to force Deadpool solo movies to
be pg-13 in the writers of the Deadpool
movies that Ryan Reynolds references
during this clip also said that they
separately had meetings with Marvel
about future Deadpool in the MCU
and they were told pretty much the same
thing they're not going to mess with the
Deadpool character now that he's owned
by Disney number 3 though Ryan Reynolds
and Fallon both referenced a ton of
deleted scenes that they had to cut out
of the first Deadpool movie in Deadpool
2 that would have gotten them
assassinated by Disney so of course we
have to see those jokes now we have to
know what all those were but if you
listen to the commentary for Deadpool to
the writers Ryan Reynolds the director
they all talked about this a little the
whole thing in having to get rid of a
lot of potentially funnier crazier jokes
had more to do with jokes specifically
about Disney and Disney brands and
people that work for Disney like Marvel
Kevin Feige stuff Disney didn't make
them take any of that stuff out the
Marvel people didn't make them take
jokes out it was actually the higher-ups
at Fox who told them that you can't do
some of this stuff mostly out of the
fear that if Deadpool went too far
ripping Disney and the Marvel people
before the buyout checks had been cashed
it might tank the deal this was all
going down while Deadpool 2 was still in
production so Fox was just playing it
safe now that really isn't a concern and
Deadpool specialty is being a mouthpiece
for the fans pointing things out shining
a light on things that totally don't
make sense like ripping all the x-men
people at Fox during both Deadpool
movies yelling about how the timelines
don't make any sense yelling about how
terrible Wolverine Origins was in his
original version of Deadpool so he went
back in time to kill him so when Ryan
Reynolds says is a potential huge win
for everyone and bringing Deadpool into
the MCU that's what he's talking about
just getting super meta with the MCU
because it's become so mature it's been
ten years in so now is the time after
these traditional MCU films when you can
start to get a little more meta number
two in terms of story the original plan
when Deadpool was still a box for
Deadpool 3 was they were actually going to
do the x-force movie right after
Deadpool 2 it was going to be Drew Goddard
doing that he was originally the person
that Sony had hired to do their sinister
six movie during the Andrew Garfield era
it would have been a proper x-force
movie with new characters in addition to
Deadpool Josh Brolin's Cable who signed
up five picture deal Domino and
negasonic
then after that x-force movie they would
have done Deadpool 3 as a smaller movie
then they would have done a bigger
x-force sequel and the intent was to
just do their own soft reboot of the
x-men universe built around Deadpool
instead of the regular x-men movies in
Wolverine because they were also doing
the Logan movie so they were getting
ready to retire the Wolverine character
too as far as they said there were never
any huge plans for Hugh Jackman to come
back as Wolverine after Logan for any
Deadpool stuff maybe funny cameo scenes
in the Deadpool movies as Hugh Jackman
cameos but not any full-blown Thor
Ragnarok style Thor Hulk crossover and I
did a video about deleted scenes a while
ago originally there were plans to
include Fantastic Four characters in
Deadpool 2 instead of doing the x-force
stuff but that was when everything was
still at Fox now that Disney and Marvel
have the characters I've already done a
couple fantastic for MCU videos we know
a couple things about their general
plans but they haven't cast anyone
officially even though it is fun to post
all the John Krasinski videos.
When I
fell face-first through the looking
glass into the what the actual heck is
going on world of fan art that's right
and finally there's this for paneler
which I have to appreciate as it'll be
the closest I ever get to playing a
comic-book hero.
[smiles]
Most of those new
Fantastic Four those new mainstream
x-men characters will be introduced very
Spider Man style ways like Captain
America Civil War where do they show up
in someone else's film then they do the
big team-up film down the road but it's
going to be a long time before we see the
new Marvel rebooted x-men film or even
the new Fantastic Four movie just
because the virus delays I'm not
expecting to see any of the bigger
mainstream x-men stuff at least until
black panther 2 and that's going to be 2022
before that's happening then number one
if you didn't see it Ryan Reynolds has
been posting a bunch of ads for the
businesses that he owns real businesses
like the Djinn ads he also bought a
mobile service one of the ads he posted
had a bunch of Deadpool Easter eggs on
it on the thumbnail of the video no less
so I'm just going to point out some of the
bigger funnier ones here there's ASMR
apparently he's getting ready to do some
of that there's the secret name of his
third daughter he's apparently planning
on having he only has two daughters
right now there's a folder that says
thoughts on time travel that's just
another Deadpool reference because of
cables time machine from the end of
Deadpool 2
this is just a funny picture of
shirtless Hugh Jackman next to a picture
of an Oscar noted inspiration there's a
blue steel Zoolander joke then there's
our two DP that's actually just a joke
reference to the new Marvel Deadpool
movie script that he's pitching to Kevin
Feige he actually met with Marvel a
while ago and posted a picture joking
about being the new Tony Stark
there's a red Deadpool folder full of
Betty White pictures the simple favors
red folder is actually just a reference
to his wife Blake Lively's movie from a
couple years ago called
a simple favor then there's a whole
section of the dashboard dedicated to
his investigation of the Deadpool test
footage leaked this is what that picture
actually looks like I've already done a
video about this he posted this last
year but I do love the Marvel Avengers
end game shout out over here on the
right so it's just a script or a joke
script for Van Wilder 2 end game
everyone let me know in the comments
though if you want Deadpool 3 to be
straight-up rated R and just outside of
the MCU is own thing or would you be
willing to let them make it pg-13 if
they can use a bunch of big Avengers
characters but if you guys didn't see
the news Marvel just stealth announced a
new Marvel Disney Plus series called
fury files is that winds up being cool
then of course I'll do videos for it but
I haven't seen any footage for it so I
can't really say anything about it right
now while you wait for everything click
here for my brand new spider-man 3
daredevil video and click here for my
new venom 2 trailer video and Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe maximum effort!